Alright.
Welcome everybody to WPS 201
architecting larger scale migrations with Fannie Mae
and the NRO.
My name is Bobby Halihan, and I'm a solution architect here
at AWS.
All right, so what are we gonna speak about today?
Um, well this is a 200 level session, we,
uh, because we're not gonna make assumptions that you know everything about migrations
and modernization, so we're gonna take
just 2 minutes, a couple minutes, and we're gonna cover,
uh, migration and modernization patterns, right, just some of
the core common, you know, bread and butter
stuff, hopefully most of you know, but if you don't, you
know, you're gonna learn something right away,
uh, from then we're gonna go into the well
application of well architected principles, and we're gonna
talk a little bit about that and how it applies
to migration and modernization
and what you'll find throughout today's discussion is.
Um, there's gonna be a theme of well
architected,
uh, and it's something that I heavily wanted to speak about
today because,
um, you know, it's a kind of a unifying
or underlying principle, right? No matter how you
do migrations, um,
especially when they're large scale,
um, being able to fall back on those well architected
principles
of like like how we do distributed compute
well, um, is just core
to all of this, right? It, it almost underpins it,
um, and, and connects it all together.
Uh, so today we have two, also
two customer stories, right? The first from the National
Reconnaissance Office or the NRO. We'll talk about
a large scale migration for a, uh,
zero fail mission.
Next, we'll then speak with Fannie Mae,
who went and redefined and retransformed
how they do financial forecasting. They're able to
take a process that took
well over 80 days and bring that into
the realm of just, you know, a few
dozen hours, like 72 hours, like something
crazy compression
of that. Um, and then throughout
the session we're gonna talk about things that you can do
today, right? So during these, uh,
big migrations, right, obviously there's lessons
learned. This isn't just gonna be a, uh,
you know, that's all, you know, uh, rainbows
and sunshine, right? There's gonna be,
you know, things are hard.
There are challenges when doing these migrations,
um, and we're gonna speak about some of that today.
We're gonna speak about lessons learned and, you know, we're really gonna
get in there.
So, without further ado, let's talk about
some common migration and modernization patterns.
So maybe some of us may be
familiar with this type of graph.
Hopefully a few people have seen it before, right? We talk about like,
um, like why, why migrate,
right? And in terms of like the value proposition,
it's really,
you know, as you migrate and modernize, your cost
of compute goes down.
Um, however, the innovation velocity, how
fast you're able to move as an organization, how quickly
you can innovate is gonna go up.
Um, so generally speaking, right, if you think
about, you know, going from on-premises to re-hosting
Amazon EC2 optimize, maybe you're going into like
serverless computer, cloud native computing.
Um, because of that, you're able to, you're
gonna be able to move much faster, right?
However,
um, And then if we take this
like one level deeper, right,
and, um, another kind of common pattern
for, uh,
you know, just migration, modernization, you know, this
type of thing is,
and you may have heard this before, we call it the seven R's
of migration, right? So we'll cover them really quickly, which
is re-host, relocate, repurchase,
retain, retire, re-platform, and refactor.
In today's talk we're actually gonna cover
I think just about every one of these will be covered,
um, to, to some extent, right? So like
pay, pay attention for that,
uh, I, I, I would say maybe commit 7
things to memory for the next 60 minutes.
Maybe that's not, not a fair ask, but, um,
um, just note, right, we will be covering a
few of these.
Um, but let's say.
You know, what if we're just starting, right? Like I don't know
when, when should I re-platform, when should I
retain, when should I retire?
How do I make those decisions
is if anyone here is in the, in this room today
and you're
thinking about doing a migration, you're in the process of a migration,
um, and you're not doing it necessarily in a
very structured way
in terms of like how you're making decisions
and you don't necessarily know where to start.
Um, there is one thing I would suggest, right,
which is taking a look at a migration readiness
assessment or MRA. And what this
is, is a,
um,
Um,
a process, I guess is a fair way to say it,
uh, that is gonna give you preparation,
uh, understanding of the types of things you need to migrate.
There's gonna be workshops, assess assessment
and outcome-focused, essentially to give you a plan
so you know,
hey, of those seven R's, which ones should we really
look at and what's gonna be most impactful for us.
Um, and this is something your account team can help you deliver
today. Now
In terms of tooling for migration, right, and
we're still covering, you know, this is still kind of like bread
and butter basics, but let's, let's, we're still gonna
talk about it because it's, it's important
and we'll see that in our assess, mobilize
and then manage and modern migrate and modernize
what you'll find is,
you know, variety of different tooling here.
For example,
in assess you can see we have right there the
migration readiness assessment,
um, but a couple like callouts I'll make,
especially if you're like starting with your
like migration journey.
Um, is,
um, application discovery service is great,
you know, you need to understand what exists on premises.
You need to understand what's, what exists there,
um, but control tower or landing zones, right,
having some sort of,
essentially like, like, you know, we call them,
you know, call it account vending machines, um, some
way to be able to provision accounts in a structured
manner,
um. It's
like you just need that if you're gonna migrate, right?
IMS,
maybe I'll even do like a poll of the audience, right? Like how many
people use like automation for, you know,
account provisioning today.
A few? OK.
Uh, how many people in the room are actually in the process of
doing a migration?
OK, awesome. Alright, so we're in the right place.
It's really good, that's really good we're in the right place,
um, so,
um, the one thing I would say, right, is,
uh, to be successful in your migrations, um,
you need to have some sort of automation in place, right?
That's gonna help you enforce compliance, it's gonna help you enforce
and standardize governance in the,
in the long run, right? This is one of those things where,
you know, it's gonna be probably a little bit of work to set
up, but it's something that's gonna pay off in full
like tenfold later because you can just,
you know, push out these accounts as often
as fast as you'd like to.
And then it gives you that type of, um, you know,
uh,
delineation between different workloads, right? So it's,
you know, the question of how many accounts do we use
becomes a lot easier because it's not a, it's not a
huge lift to actually start provisioning new things.
And then on the
Migrate modernized standpoint, right, we have things like
Snowball, Kinesis Firehose, Direct Connect of
like, OK, how are we effectively able to connect,
um, our on-premises workloads into the cloud,
right, because a lot of times when we migrate,
um, there are things where it's like, hey,
some stuff's gonna work on AWS, but it still needs to be able to
talk to something in our data centers, right?
Um, so being able to have that well established,
um, communication is important.
So, right, this sounds, this all sounds pretty easy, right?
Uh, why doesn't everybody do it? Or
I guess obviously, right, there are some challenges here, right?
And a lot of times we see customer challenges
come out with things like having diverse infrastructure
and operating system types, right? Maybe even legacy operating
system types or legacy applications,
complex databases.
Um, compatibility issues, right? Or
even
thinking about like if we're an organization and
we don't operate in the cloud today.
Like, do I have a workforce? Is my workforce
even specialized or do we have that like that corpus
of knowledge within our employees or
organization to actually effectively,
um, migrate and and perform this
transformation?
And then of course, right, tight budgets and timelines,
right? We say, OK, we'll move to the cloud, great.
Um,
but you're probably not gonna get more budget to do it.
Um, so that's, that's always gonna be a constraint
and throughout today's talk,
um, we will, you know, once again that's something I'm
gonna ask you to kind of pay attention to, right? There's some challenges
here, but we're gonna cover some more challenges in our customer
stories,
um, and I'd really, really like us to really
focus on like what we did
to overcome them.
Um,
and like think about how you can apply that today,
right, because I think that's really,
um, if we think like what's like the real heart and
core and story of this session, it's,
um, you know, it's not just to tell a good story
that, OK, yeah, they migrated, great,
right, awesome outcomes,
but how can you apply those lessons learned today?
I think that's really what you're gonna get out of today's session.
So,
Outside of just the the uh migration
and modernization patterns,
um, next I wanna speak very briefly on,
uh, the application of well architected in
in this in this domain
right so we see.
Uh, how many pillars of the well architected roofie do we
have, right? We have operational excellence, security,
reliability,
performance efficiency, cost optimization, and sustainability.
And just when we went through those seminars,
right? Like,
Uh, well architected is just, it's like bread and
butter distributed compute,
right? And
Throughout this session you will also see that
in some cases even as a solution architect when I work
with my customers and we do well architectural reviews,
one of the first questions I ask is like,
OK, what are these pillars, right, not one is more important
than the other,
but which ones are more important to you as an organization.
Um, for this workload, for this
application, does it need to be reliable? Is that
super important? Or maybe it has to be very
cost effective.
Um,
and many of these stories will find
that operational excellence, right, reliability
is very important.
Of course we all see security as like job zero for
everybody, right? I would say even argue that it's
probably,
um,
you would elevate that,
uh, or at least personally I think I like to elevate security
to think it's.
Um, not necessarily more important than the other pillars, but
we all know security is of paramount importance.
However,
In some organizations they have a very mature
security posture,
right? Um, maybe there's,
uh,
a lot of stuff as maybe as an application team
I don't necessarily
need to worry about as much of security because a lot of it's
managed we're very advanced. I, there's not
as much help I'm gonna get out of it as I
would if we could then focus on like cost optimization
or reliability,
right? Um, so.
Never that you know one's more important than the other. What we
wanna think about is like where can we get the most outcomes
and then when we think about this in the lens of migration,
don't necessarily get caught up on the fact of like,
OK, are we, are we, um, you know, retiring,
retaining, re-platforming, or rehosting,
um, you also wanna make sure that you're focusing on,
um, you know, these core principles.
I wanna reflect back on this this specific slide
here right where we talk about
um you know
like ask the hypothetical what happens
right after we migrate and what happens after
we, you know, essentially almost fully modernize
and we're at the very end of that, you know,
um, you know, the very end of that axis
right where you have like big in uh
um
innovation velocity right like what does that look
like? Um,
but also, like, even after that,
you're still gonna have a similar set of challenges.
You're still, you know.
Like, maybe if you're a startup, right?
Like you won't have to deal with legacy tech, but
I imagine most people in this room,
um, there's gonna be tech debt, there always
will be, right? You're always gonna be dealing with some of these
challenges
and. Um
Something I guess I would say in terms of,
you know, what's one thing or like
the one, the single biggest thing that you could do
um
to make sure that.
I know you're successful in these migrations, right,
and like what's one good I guess
signal, right,
that you are actively modernizing and you're doing well
in this
is that you have estab established some sort of
like cloud center of excellence,
right? We,
you, you can call them whatever you want, right, but
essentially what it is, it's gonna be
a team
from across different dimensions of your
organization, right? So from.
Uh, lead cloud architects, infrastructure
cloud engineers, security engineers,
operations engineers, and then you see your software engineers,
right? So you're bringing in people from various
different parts of your organization
to build that center of excellence, and essentially what that
is doing is,
um, you're building that in-house,
uh, expertise,
um, where you can take lessons learned, apply
them across the organization.
Um, and of course I believe both
of our, both of our stories today have our customers
have, uh, implemented, uh,
CCLEs or cloud centers of excellence, and
I would, um,
I would go as far to argue is that having these
centers of excellence help accelerate
innovation velocity.
It's so if you don't have one established,
um, think, think about establishing that
within your own organization.
Now you may ask, it's like, OK, how formal do we wanna make
it, right? Um, that's really up to you,
right? These can be informal groups, they can be
very formalized, um,
it, it's really based on how you wanna do in your organization.
Um, like, personally, I don't think it should
be very formal, right, but there should be some sort of
structure around it to make sure that, you know, there's,
you can't just have like a bunch of people that care about the
cloud, right, because,
um, one of my favorite quotes is like good intentions
don't get things done like mechanisms do, so you
do have to have like some sort of process around that,
right? OK,
so
without further ado, I wanna introduce,
uh, Shri Devi on stage, uh, from Fannie
Mae who's gonna walk us through,
uh, this enterprise transformation that they're able to do.
down. Thanks,
Bobby. Um,
let me start off with a question.
How many of you here with a show of hands,
how many of you here had to modernize
a process that's been around for decades?
Don't be shy.
All right, that was us that Fannie Mae too.
Today I'm going to talk about our
unprecedented journey to
transform financial forecasting.
It wasn't about, for us, the modernization
wasn't just about upgrading
technology, it was reimagining
how we forecast,
collaborate differently, and make
decisions
with increased confidence in our data.
My name is Shridevi Mullapurdi. I'm the vice
president for finance technology at Fannie
Mae. When
I was first asked to lead this initiative,
the mandate was to build
a cost effective and scalable
platform
that can meet both the current and
future forecasting needs.
Sound is simple and straightforward, isn't
it? I thought so too,
but the more I learned about the program,
I realized that we didn't have to solve
for the
three typical dimensions people,
process, technology.
We also had to solve for 1/4
dimension, governance,
all in a single go.
So, over the next 20 minutes
or so, I'm going to talk about
our approach,
uh, the strategic choices we made,
the lessons we have learned, both
successes and stumbles,
and the tangible results we are already
seeing. But most
importantly, I also plan to
share with you some insights
that I hope are valuable
to your own transformation journeys.
So let's get started.
First, a little bit about Fannie Mae.
Fannie Mae was founded in 1938
and is chartered by US
Congress
to advance home ownership and
promote affordable housing all
across the United States.
We are headquartered in DC and
are considered as the single largest
player in the secondary mortgage market.
What does that really mean?
So consider us as the bank for
the banks.
So Fannie Mae purchases
home loans from lenders, that is
banks,
converts them into mortgage backed securities,
and sells those to investors,
and this process creates liquidity
for the lenders
to offer new home loans, thereby
increasing the home ownership and
rental housing again in in
all of the United States.
So just in the first nine months of
2025 alone,
Fannie Mae has provided
about $287
billion worth of liquidity
to support 1.1 million
households to either purchase,
rent, or refinance a home.
So you may also know that
US housing economy
contributes up to 16%
of the nation's GDP,
and with Fannie Mae being the cornerstone
of that housing market
to provide liquidity and stability,
it is vital that
we continue to assess and strengthen
the financial future of the
of the organization,
hence the need for financial forecasting.
But you might ask me what's financial
forecasting.
Um, in its simplest form,
it's the use of current and
past financial data to predict
the financial future.
This is how we guide our business,
um, plan our business,
guide our stakeholders,
and also meet the regulatory demand.
So as part of this process,
uh, we have to do tests
on a periodic basis to simulate
the micro and macroeconomic conditions
of the market, which are called
stress tests,
right? But unlike banks, our
stress tests are actually set by FHFA,
our regulator, and not the Federal Reserve.
So our process is unique and the stakes
are high.
But why was this a hard thing to do?
So let me paint a picture. Imagine
a world of
spreadsheets,
data silos, and manual processes.
That was our reality at Fannie
Mae. Right,
and, and for us this process
did work well for many years and
it let us prioritize on
other things that were important to us,
but we quickly realized that
it was limiting our ability
to provide forward looking insights
to our stakeholders
that is again critical
in an increasingly complex environment.
In addition to the manual processes,
we also had fragmented
technology and at one point too many
technologies,
which was increasing our maintenance costs.
We also had software that
was running on-prem data centers
with end of life infrastructure.
Our subject matter experts were spread
thin across the enterprise and siloed.
So as a result of all of these, we had
significant operational challenges
that were only amplified by heavy
custommisations that we've made.
So to solve for these
challenges, we initiated the
forecast transformation program
um
in back in September of 2023
and we set ourselves some very bold
goals, right?
The first and foremost being we needed
the platform to be fast.
We needed to reduce the forecasting
life cycle from about 80
to 10 days,
right? We also wanted to run
our stress tests in parallel.
Running them sequentially was no longer an
option. We
also had to co-locate about
2,000+ calculations
that were spread across 80 different
systems
into a single unified platform,
and we wanted to run our analytics
on top of that calculated output.
We knew to do these calculations,
we had to have compute
that could scale up and down based on
the demand
and accommodate complex workflows.
And we had to do all of this with cost
in mind.
As you can see, the work was clearly cut
out for us.
So,
to, to address these requirements,
um,
we first chose AWS as
our foundation,
mainly because it offered
a, a wide variety of
both storage and database options,
and they are,
they're one of the few vendors that could, um,
meet the Fannie Mae's strictest
security guidelines.
We also wanted to persist
all of the data into a single domain,
mainly because we were
struggling with the data silos that
was in the current ecosystem.
We knew that we had to do these calculations
on about 1.5 billion
loan records,
so we needed compute,
uh, and for that we chose EMR Elastic
Mapu, as our main
compute option.
For orchestration,
after a careful evaluation, we settled
on step functions
to stitch between the data services
models and the, both the
internal and external systems.
We also consciously decided
that we were going to integrate with upstream
and downstream systems with minimal
impact to them.
And finally,
we wanted to establish reusable
frameworks, not only to
um accelerate our own development,
but also
to give back to the enterprise.
Excuse me.
So our process is actually very simple.
We start off with the user interface.
This is where
our business community comes in, um,
enters any of the inputs,
and, um, submits the scenarios
for execution.
Based on the type of scenario that
they choose to execute,
we go and source relevant data from
um multiple systems of records,
and all of that is written to the data backbone.
We then call upon
the models, both existing and
new ones that we created
as part of this ecosystem,
and the model output is also written
to the data backbone.
We then initiate a bunch of
business calculations,
and all of the calculated output
is also returned to the backbone.
And then we send off whatever is needed
to the downstream systems.
And we further prep this outputs
into uh for analytics,
uh, both for regulatory and user,
um, user analytics.
And for those of you who are interested in
the tech details,
our user interface is made up
of Angular and uh
Fargate.
The orchestration, as I mentioned before,
is a is nothing but a series of
step functions
that um get initiated
through an API.
Whenever a job gets executed.
Our calculation framework uses
the EMR option that I talked about,
and
it uh and then
it uses um the
it it then initiates the calculations
that are written in Yamu,
yet another markup language.
For us, this was our way to decouple
the business logic from the
application logic.
And our backbone itself is made up
of S3,
and we used uh
Aurora and Dynamo DB for
all of the metadata management,
and the integrations were all done
through APIs and SNS
and for analytics we use Sage
Maker and Tableau.
So you've heard me, so far you've
heard me talk about the genesis
behind our transformation,
the objectives, the process.
So how did we do our, on our implementation?
Well, we had our own share of stumbles.
At one point,
at its most active phase of the
engagement, we had over 100
engineers
on this project,
and having them all
um consistently adhere
to the guardrails and the best practices
over a period of 2 years was, was
really challenging.
Consistency was also something
that we had to
deal with when we were integrating
with about 76 integration
points across the ecosystem.
As I mentioned to you before, this platform
was going to be used for both regulatory
demands,
but also for our data science
community that needed that flexibility.
So finding that balance
to support
two different ends of the
spectrum was also a challenge that we
had to overcome.
And every scenario that we were executing
was generating about 500 terabytes
of data.
So we had to find
very quickly the right archival
strategy because
our our storage costs
were going up if we couldn't solve for that
puzzle. And then
because we were doing these calculations
on big data volumes,
we knew we needed multiple EMR
clusters.
But then
we also had to find ways to minimize
the cross AZ traffic, cross
availability zone traffic,
to reduce the for latency
and also the cost optimization.
And for the same reason.
We also needed,
we also needed to
figure out how to
Solve for the limits,
you know, whether it's an S3 lambda,
account limits, we were running into these limits
all the time,
so we had to solve for those, for that
challenge as well.
So this is where our partnership with
the AWS became critical because
they helped us solve for many of
these challenges that I just talked about.
So we started our engagement with AWS
um in August of 2024,
and we had done a series of
deep dives and workshops with them.
Uh, AWS was able to bring
in, um, their specialists,
mainly for, um, uh,
compute and storage, sorry, compute
and databases.
And through the,
through the deep dives and workshops, we
have been able to iterate and refine
our solutions.
So in addition to the deep dives, we
also leveraged AWS well architected
framework
to SSR Foundation.
For us, we specifically focused
on cost,
performance and reliability.
For us, cost optimization was
not
just a technical goal, it was
a business imperative.
So we had to use um AWS
services like uh Redshift Spectrum
and S3 partitioning,
but also we created
our own real-time cost monitoring
framework.
But my personal favorite was to show
the cost of the scenario right on
the UI
before the user even clicks on the submit
button so that they know
what they're, you know, what, what kind of a
bill they would get at the end of that execution.
And to solve for flexibility
and high availability,
we leveraged EMR's
instance fleets, which gives you an
option of mix and match between different
instance types and different processors.
So you could choose between an Intel or an
AMD or a or a Graviton
processor based on the type of workload
you are dealing with.
And then, um, on proactive
capacity management,
uh, we raised account limits. We
worked with AWS to to
raise our account quotas,
and we had used
S3 pre-partitioning
to support our
throughput of 20 million transactions
per second.
So every bit of work that
we have done to refine our
architecture
was to make was to make
the lives of our business community
a bit easier.
So, as a result of the work
that we had done, we have been able
to reduce
the cost by 39%
and then
the execution time almost by
70%.
So as to recap,
so did we meet our objective
of accelerating the forecast
and also simplifying our ecosystem?
I would say absolutely yes,
because we have been able to reduce our manual
processes by about
60%.
We have reduced our system execution
from 20 to 3 days,
and we are now able to run.
Uh, a forecast that for
36 million loan records,
uh, for every scenario, and we
can run up to 20+ scenarios
in a month.
Prior to this, we could only run
our forecast for a book
of 1.4 million loans or
so. So
we have been able to provide a modular
and auditable platform that
supports rapid innovation.
While this platform
did take about 15 squads
to develop and design,
it now we only now need
about 2 squads to support it on an
ongoing basis.
And just for reference, uh, a squad
could have between 6
to 8 engineers.
So, um,
while we did deliver on the, the
initial phase of the program,
we are continuing to work to refine
our advanced analytics
and introduce Gen AI capabilities.
We also want to extend this platform
to
the two different business lines, um,
our multi-family and capital markets,
and of course we are actively
socializing
the reusable frameworks we created
for adoption across the enterprise.
So as I conclude today's session,
let me share with you a few insights
that transcend technology.
One The first one being,
you know, modernizations like these
are marathons, not just sprints.
So please
continue to
enjoy all the wins, right? Celebrate all
the wins, whether they are big and whether
they are big or small.
Technology is just an enabler. People
drive the success,
so continue to invest in your teams.
And data quality
should be non-negotiable.
We not only consolidated all of
the data
into a single domain, but we
applied data governance on top of
that data from day one.
So as a result, we are now quickly
able to build out our Gen AI capabilities.
And finally, I would also say that
always start with the business problem and
not just technology.
Um, for us, that, that was
a big,
um,
big theme.
Um, I forgot to add one thing,
um, is embracing agility.
That was the recipe for
success. So the iterative work that
we had done with AWS
or even with our product and business
teams
helped us, um, in, in,
in this engagement.
So, as you think about your own
transformations,
what are the outcomes you would like to achieve?
For us, it was not just about better
forecasts,
it was about better decision enabling.
And Fannie Mae's journey is obviously
not finished, it's ongoing,
but we have set the foundation
to forecast with greater accuracy
and lead with increasing confidence,
and that is going to serve us and
the housing market we support for years
to come. So thank you for
your time.
I, I hope, uh,
you found the information helpful.
Please do take a little bit of time
to, uh, complete the survey and, uh,
enjoy the rest of your conference.
Thank you.